[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy football sunday it's officially
holiday season
and we're celebrating and we're happy
that you're rocking with the squad ride
live in the bleach report app presented
by
draftkings my name is cabby richards and
always bringing gifts in the form of
best bets
is our betting expert kelly stewart and
the artist
known as greg ivory is on vacation but
his cousin
grega claus is riding with the squad
kelly over under the number of hoodies
that greg's gonna give away today
i'd have to go with like 14 and a half i
feel like we're giving away at least 10
every show
okay apparently greg and claus has got
inside information he knows it's gonna
be more
i'm definitely taking the over this is
the show where we bet anytime touchdowns
with checks two boxes you can root for a
player not on your fantasy team
and whichever player you guys choose we
ride with that
is the squad ride salute to the chef
dalvin cook
we are now 10 and four so thank you for
that touchdown last week and also salute
to the pool legend
anders emily for the pick um we asked
you on friday to drop your pick or who
will score a touchdown
this week we asked you on our socials
and here is a list of the
most popular picks i'm laughing because
uh
lamar jackson is in the middle of the
screen there and he tried to flush
rumors of his absence
in that monday night football game
against cleveland and the internet was
not having it
also happy belated 23rd birthday to dk
metcalf
listen dalvin cook leads the nfl in
touchdowns and our audience
celebrated like he was our teammate like
he was their teammate
oh hello all right we're doing anytime
touchdown score
you got zeke elliott
i had a dream last night something about
vikings something about buccaneers
yo what up br betting it just snowed
somebody was cooking in the kitchen
and the bedding gods have blessed us
with dalvin cook anytime touched on
score let's get it
travis kelsey vlog of the week tj
hawkinson any 10 touchdown squad
love that dude's energy we continue with
our celebration
gregor claus did you come bringing gifts
come on cabbie it is time i got the
handy dandy santa on the
shirt right here with the ferragamo belt
don't forget the details
you see it i'm in the comments you know
what this is right here this is my handy
dandy ipad
and my guy jordan v 1623
dab santa going too hard you're walking
away with a hoodie
uh saljeet rashaumi dk
going crazy you're walking away with a
hoodie being
ben k 619 he's rocking with jk dobbins
cabbie i'm just giving them away here we
go bet fry
bet fry he threw a gif in there he's
getting a hoodie and
last but not least cabbie i know i know
yak cove tab 24.
he got brandon cooks as a lock and this
gif is actually unlocking
uh unlocking something so i'm giving him
a hoodie just for creativity
you see it here on the handy dandy ipad
captain did i give him
over and i give him away you didn't give
away enough
did i give away enough yes you did you
get it you did you gave away five
hoodies we have five
legendary videos to show you and the
last one standing is our squad ride
the videos are matched up head to head
and our producers informed us that they
are highly entertaining so let's get it
round one our first pitch
comes from ryan mcintyre nine who you
got scoring a touchdown today my g
hello hey al i know you just got off
work and stuff but this is super
important i need a lock of the week
there's a dk metcalf or lamar jackson
what the hell is a dk no it's a football
player
i just need a lock pick one lamar
jackson or dk metcalf
all right perfect thanks pal no problem
big al we got to get you watching more
football on sunday my dude come on now
uh get ready for your first yacht is the
first
tough decision on a sunday morning our
second pitch comes from
sub parlays
what's up greg and kelly total lock for
you guys sunday night football
any time touch unscore
chub baby lock it in
wow that was tremendous that was like
the entire
uh front lawn all right you've heard our
first two pitches dk metcalf with
seattle
versus nick chubb versus cleveland uh
tell us in the comments who should move
on
greg what do you think about these
pitches man
cavi i'll start off with big al and
metcalf uh
i i don't know who big al is but uh
usually when a guy names big al they
they don't mess around
but uh big al you you you got to know
who dk metcalf is i mean he's one of the
best
wide receivers in the game right now but
but but i'll give him some slack cabbie
he did select dk
plus 100 that is value that is real good
value
uh seattle taking on that washington
team now let's talk about the snow
legend i was absolutely blown away
i was blown away by that like it took
that was actually a masterpiece
uh display of performance in the snow i
mean
i wonder how long that took but let's
talk about the pit cabbie
nick chubb nick chubb facing that giants
defense
you know kelly knows that the that the
cleveland browns love to pound the ball
so uh i'm kind of torn here kelly i'm
kind of torn here
talk to me we got dk metcap nick chubb
which way you're leaning
no greg you absolutely nailed it i
watched almost every single browns game
this year
and let me tell you what happens when
they get in the red zone
i had kareem hunt on my fantasy team
kareem
would have a breakout 20-yard run here
or there
and then what do they do downright
disrespectful and give the ball to nick
chubb for the touchdown score
happened way too many times it's gonna
probably happen again today
as far as dk metcalf goes one of my
favorite players
in the league which is kind of
coincidental because he's paired up with
tyler lockett on the other side of the
ball
that being said tyler still gets a lot
of looks i know
dk should match up well against those
giants dbs but
oh i'm sorry excuse me the football team
dbs but the football team defense
is scary if you follow me on twitter i
just tweeted out i gave out a football
team because why
are friends over at draftkings just went
to seven
at seven we're betting numbers not team
so i did take the football team
i gotta go with nick chubb here uh
especially if we're getting three to one
cabbie yes sir kelly you guys know what
i'm doing i'm in the comments and to be
honest they're back and forth they are
back and forth
uh i see a bunch of gifts i got joe yan
joe yan with the uh with the nick chubb
gif
you see him running right there uh i got
bay area guy
87 he's rocking with dk um
it's back and forth in the comments
cabin is really back and forth
let me give away some hoodies brett
stephen brad stevens rocking with dk
brad stevens rocking with dk next one i
see cabbie next one i see i'm just going
to make a decision okay
next one i see because it's back and
forth uh here we go i'm just going to
spin it
land on it oh we're going with chub bay
area guy 87 i landed on it he's going
with chubb
we're rocking with nick chubb moving on
okay to the next round all right
it was hard it was a tough decision the
people didn't i mean even the comments
was
kind of confused well his videos his
video you know it was outstanding work
in the snow there so we're moving on
with sub parlays
but there are three challengers
remaining so round two
let's get it our next pitch comes from g
wheel 21
griffin wheel who created a tournament
of his own
what's going on bleacher report got a
little bracket going on here
first round we got zeke versus dk got
jonathan taylor versus tg
and the winners are going to play and
then bringing lamar for the finals he
gets a bye because he's playing the
jaguars and you're like come on
heads versus tails first up zeke
dk has your tails let's see it
heads z moving on john
taylor todd gurley
heads jonathan taylor's moving on
see it who's going to play lamar in the
finals zeke
jonathan taylor
there it is tails we're seeing jonathan
taylor
versus lamar who's it gonna be
heads lamar jackson too easy
jacksonville jaguars
squad ride let's get it bleacher report
all right corn madness legend nice
little nice little afc match up there
well done with the tournament my man
so lamar jackson back in the mix facing
nick chubb
let us know in the comments who should
move on to round three g money what'd
you think about the coin
coin madness legends video hey shout out
to my guy g will he was on the story
riding yesterday with those dogs of the
day so shout out to my guy but he just
put on a masterful show for us uh
i mean this is with a performance i mean
it's it's possibly longer than our squad
ride show
as long as he was going but uh
the pick cabbie the pick mark jackson
lamar
jackson lamar jackson facing that
jacksonville jaguars defense sitting at
minus 106.
this is looking lovely to me cabbie i
don't know about you
this is looking absolutely lovely to me
now kelly talk to me
lamar easy jacksonville defense
nick chubb facing that giants defense
it's hard i know talk to me though
i think lamar jackson looks too cheap
every time i see a price that's like
wait a minute what am i missing here
you're right the baltimore ravens are
playing
the jacksonville jaguars by all means
lamar should score here
but i will say this jacksonville's
defense has shown us some moments of
greatness
jacksonville's offense not so much so i
gotta go with like i told you what i
think is gonna be the easier pick here
now i didn't bet
the browns uh giants game i don't love
it
i didn't love the price but i'm telling
you right now nick chubb is going to be
the one to score a touchdown tonight
kelly's rocking with nick chubb but i'm
rocking with the comments here
i'm on my handy dandy ipad i got neil
deussen run a dub chub so he's rocking
with nick chubb
neal deuce you're walking away with the
hoodie jack shulman
lamar anytime td scorer gregor claus
i've been saying this all day jack
shulman you're also rocking away with a
hoodie
tnd neil b.r is saying greg show me love
t.d neil guess what i'm showing you love
it is the christmas season
you're walking away with a hoodie
brother cabbie let me get back to
let me get back to the matter at hand
the next one i select we're rocking with
all right cavs got it
here we go here we go uh oh big mike 13.
look at that
you see who's swimming can you guys see
you swimming that's lamar jackson right
there that is lamar jackson
lamar jackson is moving on cabbie the
people have spoken
they're in the comments yeah they're in
the comments lamar jackson
we're we're moving on lamar all right
lamar lamar congrats
come back to the coin madness legend g
wheel 21
and he is riding with lamar jackson and
the best rushing offense in the nfl
two more matchups to go let's get to
round three our next pick
is for our next pitch is from kyle henry
with um let's say some beautiful mind
vibes
the answer to many of life's questions
can often be found in the numbers
let's take a look my anytime touchdown
score
on sunday afternoon football if we add
up each of these letters we have
two plus seven plus nine
plus six plus two plus
six plus nine plus eight
add all those up what do you get some
quick mental math
49 49 49ers
but who my anytime touchdown score on
sunday afternoon football
will play running back and will wear
four
plus 4 plus 11
plus 3 plus 4
plus 4. add up all those numbers you get
30. who wears number 30 and plays for
the san francisco 49ers
none other than jeff wilson jr
okay okay i got two two things evidently
uh we don't have rights to that website
uh but it was uh jeff wilson jr we
promise
and greg were you following with the on
your handy dandy calculator
while our beautiful mind legend was
going through those calculations
those are my two things oh cabbie you
you know i was following as soon as he
said 49 i mean it caught my attention
you know what i mean so he's at 49
and then he started to explain you know
he started to go through the
calculations and analytics and all the
stuff
and finally came up with jeff wilson
that's funny because before the show me
and kelly were going back
and forth because i have jeff wilson on
my fantasy team oh
and i need him to have a big day so
sitting at plus 140
i actually uh i actually like this but
one thing i do got to say is that the
guys should be working for the cia or
something
the way he crunched those numbers and
analytics i mean it's like no other
it's literally like no other but jeff
wilson facing that cowboys defense i
absolutely i actually like this
now kelly it's not what i like
it's not what you like but talk to me
about the pics it's
jeff wilson lamar jackson
what are you thinking what are you
leaning well greg you and i talked about
this during rehearsal when you were
debating whether you're going to start
jeff wilson on your fantasy team and i
told you the cowboys defense
is atrocious but this one scares me
this one went from three and a half to
three that is a big
time money move that is one of the more
uh pricier moves i guess i'll say
in sports betting when you come off that
key number of
three to three and a half or back and
forth that tells you something
and that scares me for your niners team
that tells me that i think the cowboys
have a good shot to win this
we know the niners just really haven't
been the same over the last couple weeks
we all know i have the niners plus two
and a half
versus the bills the line closed at one
what do you guys want me to do
all i can do is make good bets bet the
right numbers
that is not the right number to be
laying with the niners right now
i'm going with lamar jackson kelly's
rocking what lamar jackson
cabbie she's rocking with lamar let me
get back into these comments and see who
they rocking with
i got jay johnson johnson104 he says i'm
in church right now and i think jackson
what that dudes in church i mean shouts
out to you being in church and
and on the squad right i mean i've never
seen that one before but shout out to
you you're walking away with a hoodie he
must be
my mom would not let me be on my phone
at church
oh yeah i would i would i wouldn't have
been able to get be on my phone in
church as well
but uh e brand statter lamar
winners only lamar uh e brand
this hurts me because you know we say
winners only please but i'm gonna be
i'm gonna i'm gonna give you a hoodie
today i'm gonna give you an eddie e
brand for san lamar
uh cabbie money bags is in the building
cabbie money bags it's in the building
uh here we go next one i see cabbie i'm
just going to give it away
next one i see i'm just going to give it
okay here we go
i got jay johnson back into the comments
uh
saying lamar jackson uh it's a runaway
so much slime
so much slime look at that look at the
gif you see it you see the gif it's
lamar jackson let me lift it up a little
bit there it is
lamar jackson so much slime you're
walking away with a hoodie
cabbie lamar jackson is moving on to the
next round well shout out to the book of
numbers to the homie in church right
there
so we got three rounds down griffin
wheel continues to run
with lamar jackson the reigning mvp this
is the final match up
whoever wins right whoever wins this one
is our squad ride
in week 15. so our final pitch
comes from noah borrelli who's taking us
back to the seventh grade in week 15.
what's going on sports gamblers at br
betting we have
anytime touchdown score lock of the week
book it in we got scary terry tara
mclaren
adam thielen calvin ridley jonathan
taylor
and chris godwin we're gonna do the
classic high school party
spin the bottle so whoever this
lands on is a lock
jonathan taylor stopped on giant taylor
lock in jonathan taylor against the
houston texas let's go
so many fond memories of that game all
we needed was an usher playlist in the
background
uh well doctor thank you for bringing me
back a little bit and and greg and kelly
too
so tell us in the comments if you're
rocking with the coin madness legend
and lamar jackson or the spin the bottle
legend
and jonathan taylor greg what'd you
think of our final pitch
wait cabbie spinning the bottle in your
mom's garage by yourself uh no it's
always in the basement memories
it's always in the basement and it was
always by yourself though no it was
always that much spin the bottle by
yourself
[Laughter]
i'm a bit of a lone ranger
man i mean the video shouts out to the
guy he brought back memories i'm pretty
sure to everybody in the chat
and us but let's talk about the pick
jonathan taylor
uh sitting at -182 kelly and cabbie
uh he's they're playing the houston
texans that texans defense has not been
showing up
all year ah minus 182 i actually like
the value here but you know
what we can do only we can change that
value from minus 182 to plus 300
so i don't know i i'm actually liking
this this this this taylor pick
kelly talk to me though we got lamar
jackson we got jonathan taylor
which way are you lean well you
mentioned that texans defense and i know
they've shown some moments of greatness
but not very many the problem is
is that jonathan taylor's only scored
six touchdowns this year and
we're into week 15. that makes me really
nervous
again i know we're getting three to one
here i did play the colts in a teaser
from seven and a half
six point teaser down to one and a half
so i'm cheering for the colts today
oh this is too easy the rave
the ravens are playing the jaguars
i don't know i i think i gotta go lamar
jackson here
okay well uh if you're if you're riding
with lamar jackson or jonathan taylor
get in the comments let us know about it
uh listen it was
it was all good a couple of weeks ago
for the pittsburgh steelers
now they got to get right after
back-to-back losses
and as you know kelly has an affinity
for divisional rival games because they
have more weight
so in week 15 kelly stewart what is your
best bet
gabby i know that i mentioned i don't
love this week's nfl card but i found
the atlanta falcons in an interesting
situation you have
this bucks team that yes needs to get
another win but they cannot
beat the saints in the division so do
they really this is
atlanta falcons super bowl their head
coach
used to work for the bucks everything is
lining
up for the falcons to play this game and
to play it tough this is their season
let's just be honest
atlanta is up to seven i'm shocked we
saw this one
at six six and a half i even saw some
five and a half draftkings wants to give
me a seven you know we're betting
numbers not teams
let's go falcons don't forget to put a
little sprinkle on that falcons
moneyline i think they keep it pretty
close
this is the first of the two first of
two meetings for tampa and atlanta so
uh matt ryan i know you're watching this
stream please please please
do not throw any interceptions in the
second half get on draftkings load up
the app
lock in atlanta falcons plus seven if
you're rocking with our mvp
kelly stewart so uh greg claus has a
list
he's checked it twice he's been giving
away hoodies on his handy-dandy device
kelly just gave us a gift now we want
one from the audience gregor claus
who are we riding with in week 15.
gabby i just picked up my handy dandy
ipad
and i'm going through these comments um
it's back and forth
as as every week it's it's always back
and forth uh
i see a lot of i see a lot of lamar i
see a lot of taylor
um you know what i'm gonna do i'm just
going to scroll i'm just going to scroll
the one i land on is what we're going to
ride with as a team
just like that are you guys ready just
one one shot abby that
that's how i'm going to do it it's too
much back and forth it's too it's too
much riffraff in the comments
so i'm just gonna i'm just gonna you
know
i got all right here we go scroll
bam jonathan taylor thomas
jonathan taylor we're walking with
jonathan taylor my guy max rexel there
it is
you guys can see it right oh there oh
hold on hold on i'ma get it
there it is jonathan taylor thomas looks
like we are rocking with jonathan taylor
to move on shout out to max rexel in the
gift
shouts out to you can we get the graphic
up please can we please get the graphic
up so we can show
the people that what we can only do here
on the squad ride
you see it says minus 182. let's switch
that let's switch it let's show them
what we can do let's let's show them
what we can do there it is the odds
boots just went up
to plus 300. uh make sure you guys
tap into the instagram story right after
this
because we will be riding with jonathan
taylor to score a touchdown
squad ride's been hitting this this year
kathy and kelly we've been
hitting uh so baby yeah
make sure you guys tap in but remember
put it in the comments i'm giving away
hoodies to whoever say it in the
comments
finish the statement in the comments
you're getting hoodie remember
to check with vr social for the link to
the odds boost that's very important
continue to send us your screenshots of
your winning parlays
unfortunately greg and i have not been
contributing to those screenshots but we
have a few more weeks of football
left send us your videos and your
celebrations we love seeing them
and we love showing them and we want
winners
only please okay gabby
yes sir i was getting wait i'm getting
to the intro to the outro thank you for
joining us good luck with your wagers
all that big dragon claws are we making
are you making one more appearance
before hold on hold on hold on
big mike 13 winners only shouts out to
you
we got uh b tab 24 winners only please
shout out to you all right go ahead
cabbie go ahead i'm sorry go ahead
go ahead uh lana falcons kelly's best
bet so thank you thank you to everybody
who commented
hey uh congratulations to everybody who
won uh hoodies
and we also want to salute our our most
recent legends
we have ryan mcintyre nine subpar ladies
g wheel 21 kyle kennery and noah barely
thank you very much gents have a
wonderful holiday
enjoy your football hold on cabbie
cabbie cabbie wait wait that's greg
i just it don't sit right in my system
that i haven't given away
enough hoodies i'm back into the
comments 954
abian you're walking away with hoodie
winners only piece
r nation five winners only please you're
walking away with a hoodie
joe yan i don't take losses you did not
say winner only please you're not
walking away with a hoodie here we go
gridiron god 12 winners only you we're
walking away with a hoodie cabbie should
i keep going
call me right now you should wait you
should quit you should quit
i want to catch this under ticket i'm
about to catch us under ticket it's like
30 seconds left in the fourth quarter
show should i keep going
that's it that's it time time thank you
very much
uh alongside kelly stewart grega claus
greg
greg ivory excuse me my name is cabby
richards we'll see you guys next week
and good luck with your waiters
[Music]
you